we're on season four of Haven at the
moment but what's the news about a
potential season five tell them Emily
Emily makes these decisions she's the
real boss the news is you know we are I
think as hopeful as ever um thankfully
the our you know numbers have been
strong and and so I don't from behind my
desk where I never actually said I don't
see any reason why we wouldn't continue
but as you know these things you know
change for no particular reason at any
moment so that's why we're really we've
been really pushing to try and get
people to watch live these days and keep
the ratings up and pound sci-fi or well
we're in a really cool place or whoever
to keep here we're in a really cool age
I think of television with just the
whole worldwide interweb as you would
call it because fans really make a
difference like that you know in the
past fans are fantastic and they're
great but this is the first I think kind
of generation of TV watchers where you
know their presence as a fan base really
can make an impact on a network we've
seen that from you know shows being
brought back because they've really
harassed networks to now you know the
internet presence of a fan base really
speaks volumes so we're excited to be
here at comic-con there's tons of fans
but we also love to get the message out
there that you know if our fans are
vocal and they tell the network's they
want us to come back and they spread the
word and you know they check in on
GetGlue and they're watching the telly
you know the series or talk about it
with each other or you know trend the
topic on Twitter or any of those things
that makes a difference I mean we get
emails regularly saying oh we trended at
this you know it really does make a
difference so you know our fans make a
difference on whether or not we come
back so in that way if they think you
know oh it's fine it's coming back and
they're maybe not be as vocal sometimes
that can have an effect so we say
even though we're you know pretty sure
we're coming back and we hope we're
coming back make sure that that happens
you know we love for the word to get out
that they want us back absolutely our
ritual consists of coming into the
trailer every single morning and just
going at it verbally going at it just
downloading yes everything you just come
in and it's like you start the day and
you can start the day if you it's
inevitably I would say the ritual is you
know a new cast member comes in and
whatever our energy is as a cast in the
morning it's just we attack that person
with that energy whether they like it or
not that's why I'm by going at it like
they come into the trailer and we either
if we're in like the best most hyper
mood ever they're gonna get that full
force the boys will just start hugging
on them repeatedly yeah we're pretty
well we're we're pretty immediately
welcoming mm-hmm maybe overwhelmingly so
yeah like I think people are yeah oh
yeah wonder a little what they've gotten
because thankfully they could grow to
enjoy us but I've said this before in
interviews but I'll say it again we film
on the edge of nowhere it feels like
you're not the Nova Scotia's nowhere but
it feels like that sometimes and so
whenever anyone comes in from the
outside
absolutely you know and there is and
then they have such you know they're
usually coming from somewhere relatively
far away so there is a whole culture
shock of being in this little world that
we shoot in so
I have a storage out that not now like
tell you later tell me later
and I was good and there yep go ahead
Emily has a story about about another
sci-fi person Colin Ferguson from Eureka
okay I've done many of you know event
with Colin and I tell him all the time
yes we film in a really small town we're
out in the middle of nowhere and he kind
of would be like good he came to join us
this season obviously and at the first
email slash an email which turned into a
phone call on the phone he literally
said to me I I don't know where like
literally I'm out in the middle of
nowhere like am I really I could we be
five minute I don't know I don't know
where I am and I just started laughing
at him because he's giving me such a
hard time for so long
about that like yeah it's hard filming
on location it's hard but literally he
was he woke up and he was like you guys
only have one we're like yes we know
it's really fun that's kind of
initiation in and of itself laundry
laundry and Lucas house it felt having a
new side William come into that
relationship between all three I don't
want to talk about it we could yeah
let's trade answer um know how does it
feel to have a new hmm well it I mean
it's it's great for someone for Nathan
to have someone to yeah I guess I can't
say exactly what are the nature of our
relationship is yet but to have other
characters involved in his tiny little
world tiny little brain
and and in the same way I guess for me
you know just as as the the person Lucas
that's not the character it's really
nice to have Colin around he's a great
guy and pleasure to have on set a total
ass and a lot of fun and I would say
it's been a lot of fun playing laudry
Lexie and well not so much playing
laundry laundry kind of drives me nuts
and that is to say when the two are like
going this way like it's kind of crazy
because I've I think I've fought pretty
hard throughout the season to really
clearly say who is this right now who is
this right now you know are we gonna
make it clear to the fans are we so for
the first four episodes it was really
fun playing Lexie I mean especially
episode five which I think just aired
here it was when um Lexie comes into
Haven and it was directed by a great new
director we had this year rick boda boda
and he we just had a lot of fun because
he would pull me aside and he'd say like
let's do something fun with Lexie and
that you know how can she get on
Nathan's nerves more and more and more
and so that was fun for me to play
because trying to get into his personal
space cuz you know here he's dealing
with the fact that Audrey's around but
she's not around
and so the comedic side of Lexie was
really fun to play just I I would try
things and instead of people saying like
oh no take it down a notch they'd be
like great you know you can just be
bigger and more out there but it is a
little tricky finding my way back to
Audrey and feeling like she's clear
because I feel like you know she has
Lexie so much on top of her now in so
many ways so that was a little tricky
but I tried to add so many layers to
Lexie that as Audrey begins to be
reintroduced to Haven some of those
things come off like her nose rings or
her hair
the different types of her clothes that
you sort of see her kind of blend back
into her hair falls off yeah it comes
out in the next episode it's a trouble
balding trouble I did and I wanted tell
him about tell him tell him the one
about tell him about how the tell him
tell him the story when all right told I
think I I know know I've told it anyway
oh yeah um so no I haven't I think I've
said I can't remember who I said to you
but it was really funny because you know
coming back first of all I had just had
a baby like six weeks prior so it was
all sort of I think everybody was kind
of concerned as a nice word to say we
have no clue what she's going to look
like after she has this baby and so what
are we gonna do character wise and so it
was really fun to play Lexie and just
have a completely different look
altogether and as you know our offices
our main offices are in LA we also have
some offices in Toronto and we shoot in
Nova Scotia so our production Network
studio all that's kind of spread out
across the continent so I don't exactly
get to see everyone before we start
shooting so we were starting up the
season they were developing the look for
Lexi we you know tried out a bunch of
wardrobe and came up with some photos
and you know went through hair and
makeup a bit of what we thought looked
really really good and sent that off and
everybody was like awesome looks
fantastic now we just want to see this
on Emily
and we everybody was like wait a second
no way you know which was a such a
compliment to the transformation that
had happened also was a little bit
disconcerting like you don't know who I
have this is me but it was really really
cool to actually have you know created
an entirely new look and to be so
disguised you know as an actor that's
one of my favorite things is to try to
not trick people but to try to make them
you know pull them into a story so the
fact that we had done that with our own
people was was exciting
I did fight for the nose ring though
there was a little character I played
when I got my taft-hartley which is the
first little stuff you get when you
become sag and she was a little low-rent
sort of bartender rat and she had you
know really short blonde hair and a nose
ring and I really liked her and I didn't
ever feel like I got to play her so when
they sort of pitched this character to
me I thought I think she would have you
know we want something very distinct
when you look at these people when you
take snapshots of each of these
characters from Audrey's life you want
to know who that that's her and so that
was something and I said I really think
people like I don't think it'll be too
much no but I really think and I just
kept fighting and they let it we let it
through just to see you know what
network thought and network loved it so
I got to keep it yeah that's right it
wasn't a Stephen King novel
has he got any notes down about what he
get himself away from the distance I
don't know if he's watched it talks to
Emily most days but not me actually
called he is calling yeah calling he
actually called your mom my mom said
yeah even really likes the show we got
we we know that Sam and Jim the creators
of the show got a lovely message from
him when they started you know with his
best wishes and congratulations and and
support and that meant a lot to them
they're huge fans of his and um and he's
basically let I mean he's let them do
with his material what what they would
and we're trying to get him in I think
to do a cameo perpetually there's an
open invitation it would be very cool
but I don't he doesn't he doesn't really
have an ongoing relationship with how
this shows I think he tweets either so I
don't really have a way to get in
contact
is that why there you'll get to meet
intertextual references all the other
bits of his universe that they like to
mention like Shawshank and so forth
because they've got that open eye I
think so yeah and just because they're
they're huge fans they and and we have a
bunch of huge fans in the writers room
and I think the Easter eggs now are like
mostly Nick and Brian's doing but it's
something I think that we've tried to
you know it's when the show began and it
is it is it's a spin-off of the world
from Stephen King and so we have his
blessing and we do realize that we are
you know that we mentioned him quite
frequently in reference to the show so
you you want to do him justice and you
you you know it's we have a large
fanbase of people that are fans of his
work so it's kind of a fun added bonus
for people that really read all of his
literature to be able to go through and
know everything right and there's so
much stuff in there that is like there's
so many parallels and from from very
obvious ones to completely theoretical
sort of parallels that I couldn't even
begin to talk about because I don't have
a clue but as you know you know he's got
so much material out there
his real fans is big fans I think would
have a lot of fun mining havens or
anything
when Lucas and the guys I proposed a
center and you got to be able to talk
common sense been trying avoiding a
bunch of life's messy you know therapy
and then therapy as a result yeah what
did you say we said wait what did you
say because he made a joke oh yeah
that's right that's right we did we said
that we said that you had that you were
basically like the girl surrounded by a
bunch of guys that are making like
juvenile yeah joke sorry my life but
that you had really come a long way in
fact last last year
you know gun to joke like you you've
come a long way like it sort of degress
ik - the thing is is I like to keep a
low profile on set a low profile I'm an
observer there's a lot of things like
I'd say there's a lot of things I could
say and you don't know but I do
thoroughly enjoy shock factor as well
but it's in Reverse like the boys like
to like especially Eric likes to shock
me with stuff and likes to see if I how
I'm gonna react and I like the reverse
shock factor which is just keeping it
low for a really long time and then
sending out a zinger - which they get
along long yes the very years it's
pretty awesome it's pretty awesome
no but I made a joke I think recently
about how I just spend my days on set
going like this yeah I consider myself a
refuge for the Outsiders that come in
and get you know berated by the energy
I'm like if you want to join in feel
free but if you need a place to call
home
okay no we really have a really good
time yeah but it is not it's not it's
it's not very academic although we would
really support that if we had an
academic come to Hannon and wanted to
you know pursue their studies on set
they could that would be fine but they
would just have to deal with a lot of it
is joke it's funny you know I think I
was the kind of girl growing up where I
hate to say it but I didn't have a ton
of girlfriends anyway like I attended to
like gel more with guys in general like
I just got their humor kind of was more
of a tomboy and enjoyed that company
more because it was just less drama or
so I thought
but so so I feel kind of I feel at home
it's like the brothers I never had I do
have a brother he's younger than me
yeah the brothers that I did is anything
you guys want to see all your characters
it's something that hasn't happened yet
that you would like to have a crack at
get the right to survive it for you
stuff just stuff that's there are there
are all sorts of things but that's a
really hard question to answer because
I've I've thought myself like what would
I you know okay I'm gonna go sit down
with them and talk about what I really
want to see and what do I want to see I
could I I have a hard time answering
that but I guess I guess I would like
I'd like to see a I'd like to see some
I'd like to explore some more of
Nathan's history mm-hmm
some I think there are all sorts of
story possibilities in you know his dad
his mom what happened to his dad what
happened to his mom his adoption but I
don't know if those are you know I mean
selfishly I would love to do that I
don't know if that is what the show is
supposed to be necessarily but but I
don't really know I think it's I think
it's gonna be tricky
we have knowing where we end this season
from my perspective going into next
season with a I'm gonna need a fresh set
of eyes I think I think Nathan needs a
bit of a revaluation of things and he's
he's I would I would like to see him
like have a big personality shift or
yeah I'd like to see a big change in him
hmm well I don't know how long we can
you know what well I can't say what it
is I think it's funny that he said that
though cuz I feel like when people ask
me that question I tend to usually go to
the Nathan camp of things like I feel
like he's a huge question mark which is
such a great like piece of the Haven
puzzle I think that that's a lot of the
allure of who Nathan is as a person but
I always have said like I'd like to see
his like apartment or where he lives you
know when we get a glimpse we just
recently got we get a glimpse of that
sort of but like barely two seconds of
it and I'd like to kind of I would think
it'd be kind of cool to see like
different points of view from you know
cuz we're always sort of attacking a
trouble but I think the way that maybe
like Vince and Dave view Haven or the
way that like Nathan's day and like how
he does like I think that would kind of
like an interesting spin yeah and things
and I also think there's just a layer of
mythology that we sort of held up season
one with Lucy and the chief and you know
Nathan as a little boy and Duke as a
little boy and that sort of 1983 ask
version of Haven that sort of supported
the whole first season to me it is very
interesting and I'd love to kind of give
that some more weight or delve into that
I just wanted to say from a story like
other than specifically character
perspective from a story perspective I
would love to see I think all of us
would like to see you know less less
concern about the trouble the week in
general and more you know maybe a new
way to approach episodes whether that's
you know a day in the life of a certain
character or whether that's more time
travel but more exploring that mythology
in general rather you know and and
weaving in maybe the trouble that
they're dealing with but having it
focused less on that case
you